we have this uh from the guardian
trump sues u.s government over fbi
search of mar-a-lago ex-president seeks
to prevent bureau from reading c's
documents until court official weighs in
well there's the story here's the big
important piece alan dershowitz says
every reputable attorney he's spoken
with has told him their firms won't let
them go anywhere near trump
dude
we can't survive as a country
if this cult keeps expanding and
operating this way this is why i've been
talking about why it's so important to
build culture
and for everybody to start building
industry parallel economies
these lawyers are like i can't i can't
represent trump even though trump's far
from the worst person ever ever
represented in this country
but they can't do it because they're
like oh i'll never get a job again this
means we need lawyers to make law firms
that are like we don't care if you
represent trump the aclu defended the
clan back in was the 90s i think right
when they were marching through skokie
illinois they defended unite the right
only you know a few years ago and that
was a
horrifying moment
now
the cult has expanded to the point where
lawyers aren't working with trump here's
the big here's the big thing trump when
he filed this lawsuit it was pro se
there were no lawyers signed on to it it
was just trump representing himself now
i believe some lawyers have signed on
and the left is mocking him for for it
calling his lawyers like fly-by-night
lawyers and it's like this is a bad
thing
but if you're in the cult and you're
psychotic
it's a good thing you're a communist
everybody has to fall in line and march
in lockstep it's good that no one will
represent your your enemies if we carry
on down that path
i mean you all know where where where
this ends up gestapo
i i always joke around like it's step
one control the narrative right and
we've seen it in the history playbook
you know burn the books that are against
your narrative control the media control
the news much easier back in the 40s and
step two you know just i don't need to
take the weapons right now i just didn't
know where they are just register
i might need to take certain ones and
eventually i'm gonna take all of them
and then after that step three is do
whatever the heck you want there's no
stopping you and i'm not a conspiracy
theorist but i know that i have weapons
that are for hunting and i have weapons
for defending my home and i have sworn
allegiance to
protect and defend this country against
all enemies foreign and domestic and
there are certain inalienable rights
that i will not give up and you will
have to pry
things out of my hands before you come
to my house and you mess with my
children you come to my you want to jab
them with certain things that you say
are healthy and they're not going to
cause them to have major heart problems
i'm going to say good luck coming to
savannah georgia opening up my door and
sticking something into my children
right that's not going to work out well
so what's um
that's not violence by the way i was
just saying it's the spirit of american
freedom that's the point of it let me
ask you let me ask you a question what's
a um
what's uh what's a 450 bushmaster
round four
are you familiar do you know your guns
i'm not trying to put you on the spot
i'm i'm trying to make a picture yeah so
i i'd say i have everything from a 50
cal down to 22s and every single what's
the purpose of a 450 bushmaster let's
say let's say polymer tip 450 bushmaster
you tell me at this point so again i'm
not trying to put you on the spot
hunting right big game you you get maybe
like four or five rounds in the magazine
i think so i don't hunt i'll be clear i
like i shoot targets so right i'm one of
those guys i don't believe in in killing
things uh except for bad humans
so my point here is uh that's a weapon
for for for hunting animals right sure
um what would you say like uh
bird shot is for you know 20 or 12-gauge
bird shot
birds birds yeah what's a uh barrett m82
a14 50 bmg humans
banks bad humans helicopters
and uh the thing about that is
you can buy one this is america
and so i've seen these conversations and
it's funny because
what do you think would happen i mean
what how do you think the left would
respond i mean they'd lose their minds
just knowing that you would buy such a
weapon
they would argue that the fact that
you'd have the conversation about it
would be incitement to violence or
insurrection because there is there's
not a hunting purpose technically for a
50 bmg it's like an anti-material rifle
for taking out tanks and things like
that yeah i still have access to 240
bravo machine guns on the side of the
little bird helicopters that fly around
my house and it's georgia again yeah
i've got the undertaking
shooting machine guns and just shooting
targets because it's america you know
because we can and because we're not
bothering anyone and
i i don't
i don't understand this uh
concern of the far
whatever the anti-gun
that is so
hell-bent on taking them all away when
they've never gone to the countries
where they were taken away where they
currently are taken away you know in
ukraine for example
they were all taken away and they were
all handed back out because
guess who was coming the russians right
yep and and you know
they didn't have guns and they had no
guns apparently
uh zielinski knew they were coming did
you guys see jimmy dore talking about
that today no what yeah apparently
zolinsky knew the russians were going to
attack but he didn't tell anybody
because he didn't want to take their
money out of the bank he didn't want to
crash the ukraine but everybody knew was
happening they were there
troops
our president pulled our um elements out
our president could have done a lot more
they could have done a no-fly zone
before there was a war it would not have
been an act of war to declare a no-fly
zone on ukraine by the united states
i'd say our president did the or sorry
not our president somebody during the
afghan evac put a no-fly zone um for
evacuating aircraft right
that's weird state department six
aircraft trying to pull out american
hostages what what do you call it ian
that joe biden did in afghanistan the
surrender yes surrender yes
yeah well anyway i want to go back to
this story a little bit
but basically though our country in
terms of the military um
capabilities and uh you know the
individuals that are out there willing
to do bad things to bad people and they
they are willing to lay down their lives
to do so they wanted to go and rescue
our u.s citizens that were left behind
in afghanistan they wanted to go and
provide aid to the individuals who were
fighting against russians and give them
the capability to defend their own
country at a time of need
but we actively prevented those things
it's not that we stood by and just
watched things happen we actively put a
raz around six aircraft in mazel sharif
when i was trying to pull people that
were american citizens out of
afghanistan right that actually happened
firsthand knowledge we actively
said that the russians are going to take
over this country there's nothing we can
do pull everyone out don't give them any
aid no support world stage the ngos of
the world are the ones that actually
prevented world war iii from occurring
my humble opinion i think the history
books will see it that way too because
now everyone on the brother pours money
which is wasted right all that funds is
squandered waste none of it's going to
where it actually is supposed to go and
i'm boots on the ground there i can tell
you firsthand knowledge i want to jump
back to the story though because the the
the main point that i think we need to
pay attention to is you know within the
past couple of days we're hearing that
donald trump can't get a lawyer then
we're seeing he files a lawsuit pro se
so he's gotta try and find somebody to
sign on then the left mocks him over it
this is
man this is this is this is very very
serious in terms of culture war and
leading up to either
we
look
civil war is is is actually a very
optimistic concept
civil war means
that
there's there's a chance at preventing
totalitarian takeover because the
reality is you look at weimar germany or
you look at pre-you know communist
russia and it was no civil war it was
revolution and revolution resulted in
the nazis and the soviets
so if in the united states there isn't a
civil war that would just mean these
people have taken over well you could
have a civil war that turns into a
revolution too you got to be careful
about unleashing the beast yeah but
typically what we see with like right in
weimar germany you had the communists
and the fascists they were fighting and
the fascists win but it wasn't like
a civil war necessarily it was political
conflict kind of like what we see here
and so that's that's the thing i think
people need to pay attention to they're
like oh we're not on track for a civil
war we're just seeing political violence
and it's like yeah you're seeing
political violence you're seeing the
weapons weaponization of the dog against
the former president and his
administration you're seeing
him unable to get a lawyer from any firm
and being made fun of for it i'm like
yeah that's kind of like pre-nazi
germany pre-soviet russia level stuff so
okay maybe maybe these people are happy
that there won't be some kind of civil
war and i think
in a certain sense that sounds good
doesn't it no civil war the problem is
what they're actually talking about is
violent revolutionary takeover genocide
murder etc it seems like that we're on
track for globalization somehow that we
have been for probably 20 or 30 years
and that i i was very anti-nationalism
for you know 15 years ago i was like i
screwed the u.s this war in the middle
east because the war in the middle east
was insane like unfounded he lied to get
us and george bush lied to get us in and
killed all these people and destroyed
infrastructure uh i was so fed up with
the nationalist powers being like my
country is better than your country when
it's like dude we're all humans sharing
the planet together let's let's work
together as a species let's create a
language create a currency and move on
it's very naive and then and so a decade
later now i'm looking at how dangerous
globalism can become because the
american experiment is phenomenal
objectively from well i can't be
objective about it but it's pretty cool
most people on earth seem to think it's
pretty cool this sense of freedom that
we have and if the global uh if the
world economic forum and the bank for
international settlements gets to
just dispense with nationalist
governments and create like a
corporatocracy we're screwed that's not
good that's that's a lack of freedom i
don't want it but they keep trying and i
think it's inevitable that we will
globalize somehow it's just anyone that
talks about the end of the liberal
international economy
they say that it's ending that anyone is
like so there's gonna be a new
international economy there's going to
be a new world order what's it going to
be like i used to hate the world
economic forum in klaus schwab i don't
even know the guy but now i realize i
want to talk to him because
they want sustainability they don't want
to kill everyone they want to do
something good but like you said earlier
good can be twisted
i don't know if i agree with you ian you
said uh they don't want to kill and ever
kill everybody and i would say
technically correct maybe they don't
want to kind of like i don't want to
have to go and kill all the deer when
their population has expanded too
rapidly right collateral damage you
don't want to kill all the deer because
then they're all gone and they're no the
issue is
you know
what we see from a lot of global elites
when they're saying things like the best
thing you can do for the environment
does not have kids that's the very nice
way of saying they don't want your
family to expand they don't want you to
be here okay so uh look we know because
we have a chicken city it's stinky
because we had too many so we had to
take a bunch of the boys and send them
over to cocktail which is where all the
boys go because when the chicken boys
are around each other they don't fight
but when you put a girl in there they
start fighting so uh way to separate
them and create two different little
chicken towns chicken cities the smell
was getting really bad because the the
the chicken crap couldn't get washed
away fast enough i recognize that as
someone who is literally you know we
have our own chicken coop but we also
know that uh with deer for instance if
their population isn't kept in check
they start decimating local plant life
and causing
ecological problems so then humans go
out kill a bunch of the bucks get the
population down and under control humans
are not exempt from these concepts now
there are a lot of people who think over
population is a problem that's kind of
the issue there are a lot of people who
think that overpopulation is not a
problem maybe it will be soon either way
these world economic forum people these
global elites they think it is a problem
and if you look at how we deal with
uh invasive species of any other species
why do you think that these global
elites would treat humans any
differently now i will say because
they're humans which is why the approach
is stop having kids
be live in luxury birth control they're
trying to stop human reproduction
because then naturally what happens is
the population slowly dies and then it
it contracts and shrinks down and that's
one way to control population expansion
so my clarification yeah you're right
they don't want to go around just kill
people but they certainly don't want
people to be alive anymore uncertainty
they want
not feces on the streets of new york
they want someone says not so many
people in san francisco that they're
they're clogging the system like what
you're saying about the chicken poop
which is happening in la and in new york
there is a clog right now there's too
many people in a centralized area cities
maybe are are fading away i don't know
the problem is you need electricity to
get from place to place or gas power
like maybe that's like
that's a luxury maybe what we got to do
is take out a boys from san francisco
and send them to their own human [ __ ]
town where all the boys can hang out
like we do with chickens i think they'd
like that yeah i don't think it would be
a problem so i i think maybe humans are
misappropriated on earth that we're all
stuck in these mega but then the idea of
like creating mega cities is is a world
economic i think that's an economic
forum concept by 2030 they want mega
cities which doesn't make sense
well it allows you to uh control people
way way better and the idea with mega
cities is that it keeps humans away from
the environment so there's less of an
impact on external systems
you know on the ecosystems or
surrounding areas there can be harmony
and you isolate humans certain areas i
actually think the other the opposite is
better i think we'd be better off we'd
be better off with humans spread out
quite a bit more then we need oh we need
to evolve our postal service this is
something i've been thinking we can
evolve the us postal service into a
stratospheric drone delivery program
where we can ship stuff all over the
planet
i think that would be i think what's
going to happen is initiative what's
going to happen is they're going to
increasingly digitize reality like i was
already mentioning earlier in the show
if
if the collapse happened today and the
power went down
we would have the news would be gone
like news archives would be gone you'd
have no way to boot up the internet it
would just be dead servers maybe got a
solar generator on your house
congratulations you can power your stove
you can power your air conditioning
and you got no access to information
because those data centers are all down
have you backed up wikipedia onto your
phone i'm not saying wikipedia is a
great you know unbiased uh system but
there's a lot of articles wikipedia that
are like this is what a an edible flower
looks like or something like that have
you downloaded survival guides have you
downloaded encyclopedias in general put
them all on your phone right now
like seriously it's not hard to do i
think it's like six gigs for the
summation of wikipedia and of course a
lot of the political stuff is very
biased but there's a lot of stuff on
there that's you know might end up
helping you in the long run when you're
like looking up you know drug molecules
or how currents work or something like
that electrical currents
if if the power goes down
you might have power but we lose access
to the grid so here's here's what i
think
i bring that up because it's the
direction we're going in and that's why
i said my idea for a show was people
living in pods living in the metaverse
and never coming outside because they
don't need to the matrix is the it's
seemingly the end conclusion of where
we're all going how do you stop
overpopulation put them in the pods put
them in the matrix how do you stop this
mass pollution humans crapping on the
streets put them in the pods put them in
the matrix how do you deal with with
crime there won't be crime if people are
locked in pods eating bug mash hooked
into their
locking people in pods is a crime yes
against humanity in the metaverse and
they're gonna choose to do it they're
gonna get neural linked and they're
going to live in some virtual reality
where they're superheroes and they're
not going to care that's so they want to
put people in mega cities and then put
them in the internet so that we're
spread out in the internet i put that in
quotes spread out uh virtually um but
that
maybe humans are a virus that are
spreading out of control on the planet
maybe we've almost eradicated what what
percent of animal wildlife has gone
extinct under our under our watch 90
90 plus percent of the animals on earth
i don't know about that what's the
number how many what's we're in a mass
extinction of that right not ever not
everybody agrees oh interesting okay
i've heard that then i've heard that
what'd you say i'm gonna have to google
it okay yes yes hopefully google for the
verb now
google the verb so that that argument
that humans are uh just an out of
control bacterium spreading and
consuming everything on earth i've
thought about that a lot i like to think
that i'm in this individual wondrous
you know
that i should have my own spirit candle
but but these are policies that were
enacted in certain countries like china
where they had population control where
they have people in mega cities that
they can track their whereabouts where
if you want to leave those mega cities
you have to have credit system put in
place like there are this experiment
that you're talking about is going on
right now and it's a direction that i
don't want us to go in and by the way
that when that's specific the bubble is
getting so big it's either about to
burst or it's about to split into two
bubbles and we're going to colonize mars
think about this
so the way social media censors people
the the the the powerful
elites or whatever
politicians would prefer it if we lived
our lives in a metaverse virtual world
as opposed to the real world
because the only thing you can do is
what they tell you're allowed to do
you say a naughty word
they click a button and then also in
your mouth and the metaverse is gone and
now you can't say naughty words and then
the next generation won't even know
where they just control the individuals
that are out there that you follow i
mean the rock was paid three million
dollars to go talk about uh how much he
loves covet vaccines and so did a bunch
of other politicians john cena did that
apology in in mandarin remember that
so i mean we're we're
paying with our tax dollars my my money
that i work really hard for that they've
absolutely just taken at the end of the
year is goes to these high net worth
individuals that don't really need money
that have a massive following you know
sheep that are following them saying hey
don't forgo forget to go get your second
third fourth fifth booster and wear six
masks and you know i do it so you should
do it they don't do it and they're just
getting paid money is what's driving
this in new jersey when uh the lockdown
started there was a woman live streaming
her stores products and the cops came
and shut her down
you couldn't even sell things online it
was not they were it was just
i can only say that was about shutting
down economic activity
and and what did the new york times say
the earth is healing
so you look at you look at the it's
fascinating because
actions speak louder than words and they
can come out and say they want to do
whatever they want to do i don't care
what these people say you know i learned
this lesson a long time ago people say
they want to do a lot of things and they
don't do them they'll be like man i
really want to go travel the world i had
a buddy and he was like
man i really want to travel the world
you know like i really want to go to
bali and i was like okay so go and he's
like i can't i was like why not he's
like i can't afford to go to bali dude
and then i pulled up my phone and i was
400 for a ticket i was like bro round
trip 400 bucks did you even look i mean
it's like three months out you got to
buy it early and he was like what no and
i'm like you never even looked like
don't come to me and tell me you want to
do something you never even bothered to
google it that's a that's the perfect
example but i had an individual i went
to west point with that that hit me up
saying all kinds of critical things
talking about how he would be doing so
much more if he had the
uh opportunities or the the the the
access to funds
the privilege right you did and it's hey
you know i would do a lot more with the
charitable stuff like well actually you
don't know what i do with charity and
i'm involved with this and this and this
and this but i just kind of wanted to go
down that rabbit hole like why why is it
that you can't give back to society why
don't have the money like you don't have
any money you know fine if you have no
money do you have time do you have time
to spare because the individuals that go
and say hey i really wish i could give
back to our homeless population like
there's a thousand different
opportunities to do so just go do it
it's it's individuals that just want to
go and say
i think that someone should fix the
homeless population i would do it if i
could but you know what you know you
can't you can't no you can't you can one
at a time you can you could put an
effort towards making a a a individual
put your time and energy into helping an
individual who wants to be helped you're
never going to help an individual who
doesn't want to be and that's the point
most homeless people don't want to be
helped
i i work with uh homeless veterans
that's what our charity does we build
houses for homeless veterans i'm very
tied into that specific um but i would
say that you have habitual homeless that
are
at that they have not hit that rock
bottom or they they find
the overwhelming majority of homeless
people
in you know the shelters that i worked
with refuse shelters refuse to be
involved and have chosen to be homeless
and they won't even take like
the stuff that the groups i worked with
talked about is like you could go to
them and be like can we just give you
something say get away from me i don't
watch your stuff they would they and and
these these these organizations lie i
mean they were there it was also it's
also crooked man that that's the problem
when you have these negative because
homeless individuals they do talk
they're not going to want to go back to
the same place that talks about trying
to help but they don't and wrap around
services are a thing and not like to
make this a long long long story that
the individuals that have hit rock
bottom that do want to get helped if
there are organizations
that
you know put their money where their
mouth is you know you see a change in
savannah georgia our homeless population
is is not you know completely under
control but so much better than other
cities and it's because we have a
community where we have the police the
fire the mayor for-profits nonprofits
all working together as a continuum of
care saying hey how can we help
fix this together and we start chipping
how do you eat the elephant one bite at
a time and we've been able to take
massive improvements and we see it every
single year but it's a lot of work and
it's a lot of individuals time money and
effort
but yeah it is much easier to say
it's never going to be fixed i give up
who cares and move on there is a better
system than what's going on in la what's
going on in new york and it does take a
community to come together and make this
initiative not about themselves not
about how do i raise money and look cool
on stage and then after the charity
event i go back to my normal day and i
never go and deal with one homeless
shelter one homeless person again you
know that that's where the authenticity
comes in are you doing the right thing
when no one is paying attention or are
you doing it just for the
social
uh what they call it virtue signaling
i think a really good example of the
for one i would say first
uh truth is hard to come by some things
are objectively true some things are
hard to break down because the issues
are so complex you can't possibly see
every angle of every story and so when
it comes to to complex political issues
everybody is saying like this is what's
happening this is what's happening and
they're all looking at a piece but not
the whole and that's the challenge when
it comes something like two plus two
equals four there are people lying
saying duplicate through they're
actually five and they're trying to pass
that off with their weird you know
dialectic garbage it's new math yeah new
math but uh but for most people you can
understand a simple concept like two
plus two is four and why you know but uh
for for truth it's very very difficult
when it comes to doing good things i
find that
like uh here's a really good example
i've always heard we wanna uh feed the
homeless you ever hear that yeah yeah
people are trying to feed the homeless
and i was always confused by that you
know why
they're homeless they they have they
don't have homes
no one mentioned anything about food in
fact i've seen tons of fat homeless
people so i always i would always hear
this from a lot of the activists that
i'd worked with they'd be like we want
to we want to do a food for the homeless
thing and i'll be like are homeless
people hungry and they're like
i don't know and i'm like
don't you shouldn't you home the
homeless and feed the hungry but there's
these ideas that people have
misconceptions i was playing guitar in
the subway in chicago once i had a 300
fiberglass strat acoustic just came out
back in the time this is almost 20 years
ago and this lady comes up to me and she
goes
there's a shelter on belmont
do you need a place and i was like lady
i make 40 bucks an hour and she went
what and i was like i have a fiberglass
guitar like i appreciate you're trying
to be nice but like i was like wearing
jeans and a t-shirt and playing music i
wasn't homeless but they don't
understand they don't know people think
they know and i think you know i i uh
this woman was very very nice you know i
was deeply touched that she wanted to
help but she didn't know what she was
talking about and she made a bunch of
assumptions and thus didn't actually end
up helping anything i think there's a
lot of people who feel that way like i'd
like to to feed the homeless and i'm
like that's really really awesome
but we need people to actually sit down
and figure out what the problems are and
not just try and
throw pie at the wall because it sounds
like the right thing to do one problem
in california is that there's like a
billion dollar industry to help the
homeless but the thing is they don't
really want to end homelessness because
then the industry is gone joe rogan's
been talking a lot about this he's had
guests on that are talking the experts
in this so they they want to continue to
have homeless people so they keep
getting their billions every year to
keep their jobs like their middle
management jobs and things which is
absolutely i mean
if you ever have to deal with hud and
you have to deal with the bureaucracy
routine taking government money to deal
with the homeless then you start
realizing why it's never being fixed
right so if i try to create a program
which we have which is uh how do you
have housing first right not housing
only so i have tiny homes that gets
people off the street gets them put into
an individual house from there they get
taught aquaponics from georgia southern
partnership right with education so they
have a new sense of
uh pride that they could accomplish
something and then we give them job
placement right so you go from housing
first then some type of trade craft then
an employment opportunity now you cycle
that person out and you fill that house
with the next person it's a triage right
when i tell people at the triage they
get really mad right especially the the
bleeding heart leftists that have no
intention of actually fixing anything
they just want to tell me how i'm doing
it wrong
so it's hey why are you only taking
these people is it because you're racist
like actually i don't look at anything
other than a specific questionnaire that
has to do with their military records
right but that is racist to them yeah
because you're supposed to discriminate
i guess i'm doing it right
it's just funny because when you have
people who want to go and tell you how
you're doing it wrong and you ask them
how many times you go on and walk
underneath the bridge and talk to these
individuals how many times have you
actually sat down and said how did you
get here and how can i help you you know
there's so many different situations and
that's where it says like it depends
politics is a perfect example with with
homelessness right this
it's actually you know you're giving me
an idea we could solve our security
issues and the swattings by just lining
the property with tiny homes and letting
you know and helping the homeless being
like we got a place for you we're going
to teach you how to use it give them a
nice place to live and then you've got
this like community and then you're just
in the middle and they're you know your
perimeter so you want me to fast forward
just tell you what what actually
happened a couple years later with once
the city got involved on first project
yeah what did they do they made it so
much better they got rid of all the
things that we were doing that were
successful and made it permanent housing
and they allowed camps all around it and
right before the elections they paid for
everyone to get food and pizza and told
them how
when they help support the new president
coming and getting elected right because
they allowed them to go
you know register all together in
georgia right a huge swaths of homeless
population in atlanta and savannah and
other metropolitan cities you had these
organizers going to these camps and
telling people hey you're homeless
because of
these bad policies not the people we're
trying to help you right now like we're
going to do so much better so here's how
you register just use this address even
though that's illegal but just use all
you guys use this one address not yours
and then we'll come back and we'll make
sure that we take you guys to go get you
know vote properly and here's some food
and here's a new tent and here's all
that they come out of the woodwork right
before weeks before and then as soon as
the election's over
like a fart in the wind nowhere to be
found
false hope is like blasphemous in my
opinion but yes guess who will be out
there right before the midterms same
group of community organizers telling me
that i'm
a horrible person who doesn't know how
to solve this problem but they're going
to come in last minute give some people
some pizza right yep what do they say uh
give a man a fish feed them for a day
teach them a fish they don't want to
teach you how to fish they don't want to
teach you how to become independent they
have created a new modern slavery where
if you have an individual who is so
dependent on you right i need this
government housing i need this
government credit card for food i need
this government cell phone by the way i
get my real money through cash or some
type of illicit means so i don't declare
income but i'm so dependent on this
awesome group that's given me all this
free stuff that's how i need to vote and
it gets ingrained in their mind that
they have to vote
for the left so they can keep getting
these free things as opposed to vote for
the
organization that wants to empower you
that wants to make it so that you have a
sense of purpose and can generate
revenue on your own and live on your own
who was that guy who said um
something about democracy will end when
when politicians discover they can
simply pay people to vote for them by
you know through the through the
government coffee or something like that
that's exactly what you've heard that
right yeah recently i mean i've heard it
recently yeah he was like once positions
realize they can just bribe the the
population through with their own tax
money then but how are we not doing that
that's literally what's happening
they're saying like
we'll take the money that everyone's
giving us and then give it to you no i'm
going to give you 500 don't pay
attention to 3m i gave them 3 billion
you know don't pay attention to my other
buddy over here at solarcity i gave them
trillions
but i gave you 500 bucks remember that
by the way 500 bucks will buy you two
tanks of gas at this point in time and
that's us too but don't remember don't
forget that we gave you 500 dude
sorry i'm just going to say that the
system creates dependencies so if you
start to say oh well you know we might
be able to get you off unemployment we
may be able to get you off government
benefits people start to get stressed
because they don't understand what
you'll transition to and that's security
in hand when we built a drop-off we
didn't build an escalating scale where
as you make two dollars more we reduce a
dollar of dependency it's i want to give
an employee a 50 cent raise from like 13
13 50. it was a couple years ago and
this person came to me you know this was
a homeless person this was someone that
we took off the street that i just saw
working really hard on the weekends i
work on the weekends
and he told me like hey what are you
saving up for i'm saving up for a house
oh cool where do you live now in my car
i'm like holy crap you're a veteran you
work for me like we have to fix these
things but when i went to go give this
person a raise
you know it was explained that if i get
this raise i will lose essentially
twenty thousand dollars in benefits you
know i'll lose my my uh ebt card i'll
lose my phone i'll lose all these
different incentives but there's no
elevated scale down right it's once you
hit this marker you lose all of these
things so there's no incentive to make
that extra 50 cents and then an extra 50
cents that extra 50 cents if you were to
have a
i don't know a business person in charge
or someone who actually doesn't want
dependency it would be an elevated scale
you know for every two dollars that
you're making like i said you know we're
going to reduce your your government
assistance by 50 cents you know a
quarter of that so you know i want to
make an extra 50 cents i'm only going to
lose you know 10 cents worth of my
incentives thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast
but if you want to check out the full
show live tune in monday through friday
at 8pm and if you want more special
access content head over to timcast.com
and become a member your membership
helps sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there
you